Borat, such a classic
people love the film Borat
(audience cheering and clapping)
There he is.
I'm imagining it's hard to believe.
It's so much wild, insane
stuff having in that movie.
But I'm told there is some stuff that
ended up on the cutting room floor
that no one ever got to see.
Yes yes. There's one
Anything we should hear about?
There's one scene I always liked
and I had this dilemma whether to put it
in the final cut, in the
end it didn't make it
but there was a scene where
Borat was tryna get work.
He was out of money
and it's off the I'd have the naked fight.
The guy it's out of my face.
(audience giggling laughing)
That's another story.
Yeah.
An unpleasant one
(audience laughing)
and so Borat gets a job
as a porno star.
(audience laughing)
[Conan O'Brien laughing] Right.
And so there was, so we had a
real porno movie being shot,
in a hotel room
and the idea was a couple of having sex
and I was playing room service.
[Conan O'Brien laughing] Yeah.
(audience laughing)
You know I'd come in and start having sex.
So the guy shout to action.
And this is real?
Yes. This is real.
It's a real porno movie?
This is the real porno movie,
real genitals
Real director everything?
Yes exactly.
So I knock on the door, you
know, they're having sex.
I come in and they're having sex and I go.
Yeah no problem I return and
(Conan O'Brien laughing)
(audience laughing, clapping and cheering)
Thank you.
Anyway the director shouts
cut and he goes, no, no no.
You come in, you see the girls
the girl and the girl, you go, you know,
take out your takes your
(bleeping sound) out
and you start doing it.
[Conan laughing] Right.
(audience laughing) You
know, not very pleasant guy.
[Conan O'Brien Laughing] Yeah.
I go okay. I understand.
And I come back in
and he goes, all right action.
I come back in again,
knocking the door, come in.
I go. Oh, you're still
doing, I return again.
(Conan O'Brien laughing)
(audience laughing)
He says. No cut, cut, cut
and he explained to me, you know
you've gotta, you have to
have sex with this woman.
[Conan O'Brien Laughing]
Right, right, right
Not this one.
Right.
(audience laughing)
With you.
And so finally Borat,
I as Borat get it, I go.
Okay I have a sexy time.
Everybody please leave the room.
(audience laughing)
And he goes no the cameras
have to stay in the room.
(Conan O'Brien laughing)
I go, why would you have a cameras
when I'm gonna have sexy time?
(Conan O'Brien laughing)
(audience laughing)
He said, because we're making a movie
and I go. Alright, so Venture get then.
Then I said. Okay the problem is
she have no hair on her pubis.
I cannot be, it cannot go
out, but cannot become turgid.
(Conan O'Brien laughing)
(audience laughing)
And he goes.
Yeah, obviously she doesn't
have any hair on her pubis.
I go. Does she have a nuclear retardation?
(Conan O'Brien laughing)
(audience laughing)
Anyway I say listen.
I go. I cannot man kids
when she have no hair
and he said, he gets so frustrated.
They say. It's all right, you know what?
We're going to put some hair on,
(audience laughing)
on that area.
[Conan O'Brien] It's insane.Yeah
It's insane.
So this is over an hour. He
go.We're gonna put some hair
in that area and goes.
Where are we going to get some hair?
He goes, you know what?
I've had enough.
I'm going to cut my own hair.
(audience laughing)
So cut to me on the phone.
Hello, room service?
we'd like some scissors to
remove their hair from this director,
so we can put it on this lady's pubis.
(Conan O'Brien laughing)
(audience laughing)
Any. Anyway, they bring up scissors.
[Conan O'Brien Laughing] Oh no, no
They bring up scissors he chops
his hair and he glues it to her crotch.
[Conan O'Brien laughing] Mhmm.
And I say, okay great.
Now I will take my prophylactic.
And I bring out
this huge leather condom.
(audience laughing)
I go, my father (indistinct)
(Conan O'Brien laughing)
(audience laughing)
(audience clapping)
And they say.
He goes. No, no, no
prophylactics, no condoms.
And I go. Okay great, no problem.
We'll have a sexy time.
I love a sexy time.
I have had a syphilis
over 24 times
(audience laughing)
and she said, syphilis, I'm not doing it.
(Conan O'Brien laughing)
(audience laughing)
That was it.
[Conan O'Brien laughing] And
that's how you got out of it?
That's how I got out of it.
I love it.